questo è il pianeta terra questa
meravigliosa sfera blu verde e bianca è
la culla dell'umanità dove la nostra
civiltà è nata e cresciuta e si sta
sviluppando la foto che vedete è stata
scattata da una missione apollo apollo
17 poco prima di arrivare sulla luna
negli anni 70
bellissima e a me piace sempre vedere un
po più in là e quindi adesso vi porto
con me in una viaggio del tempo quindi
non viaggio breve un salto molto piccolo
qualche decina d'anni nel futuro
questa è la luna è quello che vedete un
albergo tra qualche decina d'anni noi
potremmo prendere e farci una settimana
di vacanza sulla luna ci sarà chi ci
lavora e ci sarà chi ci va per svago
questa è un'idea reale è un progetto
costato diversi milioni di dollari di
alcune catene
di alberghi tra le più famose al mondo
vi porto ancora più in là qualche altra
decina d'anni nel futuro
qualcuno di voi probabilmente avrà paura
di volare nessun problema nello spazio
non ci sarà più bisogno di volare ci
sarà un ascensore spaziale che parte
dalla terra e arriva non solo nelle
stazioni orbitanti negli alberghi sulla
luna che abbiamo visto prima ma sarà una
piattaforma per spingerci ancora più in
là questo sistema di trasporto
permetterà di risparmiare centinaia di
milioni di dollari in investimenti su
quello che oggi invece si utilizza
quindi i lanciatori per lanciare in
orbita i satelliti o i mezzi di
trasporto attuali di nuovo facciamo un
altro salto in avanti ancora qualche
decina d'anni
il pianeta rosso marte
come tutti noi lo conosciamo
in realtà quello che vedremo in futuro
non sarà una landa polverosa come quelle
immagini dei rover che oggi sono sulla
superficie marziana
inizialmente ci saranno delle serre dove
coltivo coltiveremo del cibo per
sopravvivere e successivamente il
pianeta verrà terrà formato e ci vivremo
come oggi viviamo sulla terra ci saranno
boschi ci sarà aria ci saranno dei parco
giochi ci saranno degli uffici ma
spingiamoci ancora in la facciamo un
altro salto
in futuro noi potremmo circolare
liberamente tra i pianeti del nostro
sistema solare ad esempio utilizzando
questa chiamiamola autostrada
interplanetaria che utilizza un sistema
estremamente efficiente di bilanciamento
delle forze gravitazionali dai vari
pianeti per spostarsi facilmente da un
pianeta all'altro e se volessimo andare
ancora oltre
immaginate dove l'essere umano potrebbe
essere potremmo colonizzare altri
pianeti altri sistemi solari addirittura
altre galassie stiamo parlando
ovviamente centinaia forse migliaia di
anni
non importa tutto questo esiste sono
sono piani sono progetti in cui sono
stati investiti denari e cervelli quindi
sono progetti reali
che verranno messe in pratica nei
prossimi anni nelle prossime decine
magari centinaia d'anni
peccato che tutto questo potrebbe
davvero rimanere solo nei libri di
fantascienza
facciamo un salto indietro torniamo ad
oggi torniamo alla nostra amatissima
terra e vediamo che cosa sta succedendo
allora queste immagini le conoscete
abbiamo disboscato chilometri quadrati
di foreste e le foreste producono
ossigeno e l'ossigeno ci dà la vita ci
permette di respirare
abbiamo inquinato l'acqua e non un
essere umano senza acqua non può che
sopravvivere per qualche giorno abbiamo
inquinato l'aria allora l'aria
l'atmosfera è una cosa spettacolare
l'immagine della terra prima l'avete
vista la terra è grande ha un raggio di
più di 6000 km l'atmosfera sono appena
un centinaio di chilometri immaginate è
un guscio sottilissimo ed è quel guscio
che ci permette di vivere su questo
pianeta
vi viene in mente una storiella che mi
racconta un amico carissimo ogni volta
che vengo a milano lui mi racconta
sempre la stessa cosa perché sono
l'ingegnere lo spaziale fa più o meno
così sono due pianeti che si incontrano
nello spazio e uno fa l'altro ciao terra
caspita sono milioni di anni che non ti
vedo
e la terra e si sa come non è che passo
di qua proprio tutti i giorni fa terra
ma cosa succede ti vedo ti vedo un po
pallida e fa guarda non non parlarmene
sono stato dal dottore mi ha detto che
mi sono preso l'uomo sapiens fa caspita
e grave
grave e no è un po fastidioso ma non ti
preoccupare il dottore mi ha detto che
tanto poi passa
allora in realtà a noi esseri umani per
fortuna il cervello ce l'abbiamo quindi
un po queste cose le stiamo capendo il
lavoro da fare ce n'è ancora tanto però
abbiamo cominciato stiamo investendo in
energie rinnovabili
stiamo cominciando a regina a ragionare
a livello industriale a ciclo chiuso in
modo da non avere impatti abbiamo capito
l'importanza fondamentale dei bisogni di
ciascuno di noi che devono essere
soddisfatti i bisogni i bisogni primari
e quindi qualcosa stiamo facendo ma
stiamo ancora ovviamente mettendo le
nostre mani un po in tutti i settori
abbiamo visto terra abbiamo visto acqua
abbiamo visto aria e stiamo creando
degli enormi danni anche nello spazio
quindi sto parlando dei detriti spaziali
attorno alla terra come vedete ci sono
più di 6mila satelliti
solo 900 funzionano tutti gli altri sono
lì che vagano incontrollati a 30.000
chilometri all'ora per intenderci stiamo
parlando di 30 volte la velocità di un
proiettile a rischio di andare a
sbattere uno contro l'altro generando
frammenti ci sono già centinaia di
milioni di frammenti attorno alla terra
e anche solo un piccolo pezzo di vernice
potrebbe passare da parte a parte un
satellite distruggerlo questi oggetti
girovagando diciamo attorno alla terra
quelli più vicini alla terra prima o poi
cadono
un oggetto sta per cadere nelle prossime
48 ore sulla terra ancora nessuno sa né
dove né quando quelli che vedete non
sono diciamo mobili da giardino un po
bizzarri sono satelliti o pezzi di
satelliti caduti vicino alle nostre case
e questo è un problema che continua a
crescere nei prossimi otto anni
lanceremo altri 1.200 satelliti e la
densità di questi oggetti attorno alla
terra sta crescendo con un trend
esponenziale e si potrebbe arrivare ad
una situazione che aveva descritto
kessler che uno scienziato nasa
che già negli anni settanta stava stava
ragionando sui detriti spaziali questa
situazione in cui si potrebbe creare una
collisione a catena che porterebbe alla
distruzione di tutti i satelliti attorno
alla terra e creando quindi una nube di
detriti è tale per cui non riusciremo
più a lanciare più nulla non potremo più
mettere il naso fuori dall'atmosfera
perché poi questi detritici colpirebbero
c visto che ti distruggere
distruggerebbero qualsiasi cosa noi
tentassimo di mettere in orbita e allora
qualcuno di voi penserà e chissenefrega
abbiamo l'acqua inquinata l'aria
inquinata la terra inquinata abbiamo
problemi sociali abbiamo problemi
politici chissenefrega dello spazio
vero ma non vero la maggior parte della
tecnologia che noi oggi utilizziamo in
realtà arriva dallo spazio
vi ricordate quando eravamo bambini per
chiamare negli stati uniti bisognava
chiamare un centralino prenotare la
telefonata farsi richiamare e mettersi
in comunicazione poi con gli stati uniti
oggi chiunque di voi prende il cellulare
chiama qualsiasi persona in qualsiasi
parte del mondo in 0,5 secondi
quanti di voi prende un aereo almeno una
volta l'anno
immaginate quanto sarebbe difficile
spostarsi da un continente all'altro
senza gps
ma pensate anche solo l'agricoltura ai
satelliti metereologici satelliti che
monitorano gli oceani gli incendi i
terremoti
i satelliti che danno una mano ai medici
nelle nei paesi in via di sviluppo
fornendo loro dati in tempo reale dalle
dalle cliniche magari negli stati uniti
e in europa tutto questo potrebbe non
esserci più tutto questo e molto altro
quindi questo è quello a cui potremo
arrivare
ci sono oggetti al di fuori della terra
molto grasse molto grandi asteroidi uno
è caduto in russia poco tempo fa uno è
caduto sulla terra 60 milioni di anni fa
ed è grazie a quello che diciamo grazie
a quello in cui
noi come civiltà come esseri umani siamo
riusciti ad esistere portando però
all'estinzione una specie che c'era
prima e questi oggetti viaggiano attorno
alla terra allora immaginate la
situazione noi siamo relegati su questo
pianeta su questa meravigliosa astronave
che viaggia nel sistema nel sistema
solare però è l'unico posto dove noi
siamo questi oggetti continuano a
incrociare le nostre traiettorie questi
grossi asteroidi grandi km potrebbero
venirci addosso e noi non sappiamo
l'effetto che potrebbe avere potrebbero
portarci all'estinzione quindi noi
dobbiamo avere la capacità come abbiamo
fatto dai tempi dei fenici di espanderci
di trovare nuovi posti dove poter vivere
e dobbiamo farlo in modo intelligente
altrimenti rischi e rischieremo tra 50
anni o 100 anni di non esserci più
spaventati in realtà l'obiettivo non è
di farvi fare queste facce di spavento
l'obiettivo è dirvi sì signori abbiamo
un problema abbiamo problema di cui
magari qualcuno di voi neanche aveva mai
sentito parlare un problema è visibile
sopra le nostre teste però c'è qualcuno
che ci sta pensando ci sono
organizzazioni internazionali c'è nasa e
l'agenzia spaziale europea grandi
aziende che operano nel settore spaziale
che stanno progettando queste missioni
per andare a recuperare i satelliti
morti ci sono ancora diversi problemi
uno alla tecnologia la tecnologia oggi
ancora non esiste non esiste il sistema
fatto e finito per andare a recuperare
non si sa come fare ci sono problemi
politici
legali oggi un russo non può rimuovere
un satellite americano un'americana non
può rimuovere un satellite cinese quindi
anche questo è è da risolvere e
soprattutto c'è un problema di base c'è
un problema di prospettiva
questi sistemi queste grosse missioni
ultra complicate prevedono di riuscire a
rimuovere sulla carta da 5 10 satelliti
all'anno ma abbiamo detto prima che ne
lanciamo almeno cento ogni anno quindi
cento su 10 giu c'è qualcosa che non
torna queste soluzioni da sole non
bastano bisogna fare un cambio di
prospettiva bisogna ragionare in modo
sistemico e fare in modo che tutto ciò
che noi lanciamo nello spazio come primo
passo possa essere rimosso quando non
serve più
ed è qui che entriamo in gioco noi noi
di di orbit società che ho fondato due
anni fa e che sta sviluppando dei motori
intelligenti da attaccare sui satelliti
in modo tale da rimuovere i satelliti a
fine vita quando non servono più in modo
rapido controllato e sicuro e questa
idea come come tantissime idee è nata è
nata da un sogno il sogno di andare
nello spazio ea un certo punto lungo il
mio percorso verso lo spazio mi sono
reso conto che lo spazio non solo non
potrebbe più essere disponibile per me
ma neanche per nessun altro aspetta se
davvero voglia andare nello spazio
cerchiamo almeno di di riuscire a
rimanerci per più di qualche secondo e
quindi ho cominciato a pensare ad una
soluzione che non fosse la soluzione
classica di andare a recuperare i
satelliti ma pensando ad un percorso un
percorso che potesse permettere a noi di
arrivare in quel futuro che vi ho
mostrato prima e quindi con questo pezzo
di carta sono volato in silicon valley
negli stati uniti fatto un periodo in
nasa e da lì quel quell'idea quel
concetto è diventato un piano
industriale
nel 2010 sono rientrato in italia ho
trovato un fondo d'investimento italiano
va in cerca pitanti ha creduto da subito
nell'idea che ancora oggi ci accompagna
e insieme con altri tre italiani che
lavoravano in altre aziende europee nel
settore spazio a marzo del 2011 è nata
l'azienda questa azienda che oggi ha 13
persone tutte appassionatissime di
spazio e con una gran voglia di fare la
differenza di avere un impatto positivo
sulla società
queste persone lavorano per assicurare
un accesso pulito e sicuro allo spazio e
dicevo il nostro dispositivo è un motore
intelligente quindi dotato di una certa
intelligenza e funziona in maniera
abbastanza semplice si installa su
satellite il satellite va in orbita fa
quello che deve fare quindi per le
comunicazioni foto della terra quando
finisce da terra è possibile comandare
direttamente le nostre satellite che lo
spinge il satellite vicino alla terra lo
fa rientrare in atmosfera dove brucia
oppure lo spinge in un'orbita di
parcheggio più lontana dove non può
creare danni a nessuno in attesa che
magari in futuro con una tecnologia che
oggi non c'è possano essere recuperati
questi satelliti e magari riciclati
direttamente in orbita chiaramente è un
dispositivo che deve essere indipendente
dal satellite deve funzionare anche
quando il satellite non funziona e
soprattutto deve rimuovere satellite in
poco tempo pensate che oggi è ammesso
rimuovere un satellite vicino alla terra
in 25 anni ma abbiamo detto prima che la
densità dei di questi detriti sta
aumentando in modo esponenziale non
abbiamo 25 anni noi rimuoviamo in 40
minuti
e se qualcuno di voi sta pensando di
comprarsi un satellite e volesse
metterci a bordo il nostro dispositivo
non solo non avrebbe più problemi più
grattacapi diciamo per per la rimozione
del satellite ma potrebbe addirittura
farci più soldi e questo è un bel
vantaggio per chi oggi invece il
problema lo crea
e se invece qualcun altro non fosse
interessato a comprare un satellite ma
fosse interessato ad un'assicurazione
sulla vita contro la caduta dei
satelliti che abbiamo visto prima ecco
anche su quello non vi preoccupate
perché quando noi rimuoviamo sappiamo
esattamente dove stanno andando a cadere
e dicevo il progetto è nato nel 2011 e
nel 2012 abbiamo realizzato il primo
dimostratore che abbiamo testato questo
è sono alcune immagini del test che
abbiamo fatto in germania
quest'anno quindi un anno di differenza
abbiamo qualificato il cervello del
nostro dispositivo per farlo funzionare
nello spazio quindi per resistere ai
carichi che diciamo alle alle forze alle
vibrazioni del lanciatore e poi per
farlo funzionare nel mondo spaziale e
adesso tra due settimane questo oggetto
verrà mandato in orbita dalla russia e
verrà testato nello spazio quindi il
passo successivo sarà la
commercializzazione del prodotto e
riuscire ad installarlo su tutti i
satelliti che che partiranno da oggi da
oggi in poi e questo è il nostro diciamo
piccolo ma fondamentale contributo al
primo passo per risolvere i problemi dei
detriti spaziali che noi consideriamo
veramente un collo di bottiglia per
tutto lo sviluppo dell'attività
commerciale del pianeta terra
tra qualche centinaio da anni nel futuro
ci guarderemo indietro e probabilmente
sorrideremo un po come facciamo oggi
pensando al medioevo no sorrideremo
pensando a quanto fosse in realtà facile
progettare le nostre attività umane di
svago di business in modo intelligente e
costruttivo e
strategico
e quello che possiamo fare però noi oggi
sempre su questa meravigliosa sfera blu
sulla nostra strona ve terra
beh noi oggi abbiamo la capacità di di
poter progettare il nostro futuro di
volere un futuro che sia capace di
futuro quindi sappiamo dove vogliamo
arrivare e conosciamo bene quello che
abbiamo a disposizione perché tutte le
risorse che abbiamo a disposizione sono
lì sono su questa sfera
quindi sappiamo dove vogliamo arrivare
sappiamo da dove possiamo partire a
questo punto ciascuno di noi ognuno nel
proprio ambito può rimboccarsi le
maniche chi a casa chi opera sulla terra
chi opera sull'acqua che opera nell'aria
e chi opera nello spazio per creare un
futuro capace di futuro quindi grazie a
tutti e buon lavoro